[Music]
this morning a special edition of our
morning rounds Medical News Alzheimer's
disease is a growing health crisis more
than five million Americans are
estimated to have it and that number
could top 15 million by 2050 British
neuroscientist Joseph chabela has
studied Alzheimer's throughout his
career and recently went on a journey of
discovery that produced his new book
that's out now in pursuit of memory the
fight against Alzheimer's dr. Joe jebel
II welcome hi to be with you what
motivated you to go on this this well it
turned out to be a very personal journey
didn't it did yeah so I first became
interested in out signers after seeing
it in my grandfather when I was a
teenager he was going through the
process of Alzheimer's disease and like
many people I just wanted answers you
know what is this disease what's
happening to him and how can we stop it
and that's so that's how I sort of
became interested in in the field and I
then sort of decided to write the book
because I wanted to give the public an
accessible account of where we are in
terms of the research you know what the
history of the research is and how we've
got to where we are and ultimately where
we're headed in the future by 2050 it is
expected to overtake cancer to be the
world's second leading cause of death
clearly something that's affecting
millions of people around the world what
is the difference between Alzheimer's
and dementia
sure so dementia just describes the set
of symptoms that you see in an out sinus
patient such as memory loss navigational
loss confusion just problems and general
thinking ability but out Simas describes
the underlying disease process so a good
way to think of it is is it's like it's
like saying oh so if you say someone has
dementia it's like saying they had
cancer without identifying which type of
cancer they had so out Symonds it's just
a type of dementia in the same way you
have different types of cancer you go
back to the origins and through the
history of Alzheimer's how much is the
attitude toward the disease changed over
the years Oh massively massively so so
you know as I document in the book it's
we've gone from essentially fear and
indifference to understanding and hope
when the German psychiatrist dr. alloy
out Simon described the disease in 1906
he was essentially ignored by his peers
because at the time the idea of linking
a biological manifestation in the brain
to a behavioral manifestation which is
the very unusual
alien concept it's very obvious to us
now so it took a long time for
researchers to finally wake up to this
problem and you know in the 60s and 70s
out science was essentially rediscovered
by some amazing psychiatrists like the
hungarian martin wroath and the english
microscopy Michael Kidd and since then
we've sort of had a Renault reawakening
about what outsiders is and
understanding that it is a disease
process and it's something that will
yield to science and reason in the same
way that cancer will and when you talk
about early warning signs you give
examples of somebody miss placing their
keys and being alarmed and you say
that's not what should alarm you what
should alarm you is if you don't
remember what keys are for yeah exactly
you know it's it's forgetting where your
car keys are your glasses are normal
everyone has every day for guessing as
they age and you probably weren't paying
enough attention to the memory you're
probably bit tired it's when you find
things like your keys and your glasses
and you think hang on what are these for
it's when that confusion sets in that's
when it's a sign of something a bit more
sinister and something that you should
then really consider you know going to
see a doctor about a loss of mobility
it's an early sign - yeah exactly loss
of navigation yeah it's a really great
research came out last year showing that
that's actually one of the first signs
even maybe before memory loss itself
that loss of navigation getting lost
might be one of the earliest signs you
talked about how we've moved from fear
towards hope how close are we to a
breakthrough at this point sure so the
most optimistic estimates and it's one
that I kind of ascribe to because I'm a
natural optimist is between 10 to 20
years that we will at least have an
effective treatment because what we
really need to do is push the illness
back you know the cure for Alzheimer's
is actually not what many people think
it'll be a treatment that just pushes it
back if we can push it back by a year
there'll be 9 million fewer cases of it
by 2030 well if we can push it back by 5
years that will essentially - half the
globe's 46 million sufferers of out
Simas disease now so really we just need
to push it back change the course of the
disease itself so the victim never has
to experience any of the symptoms of the
disease by pushing it back you mean they
they will succumb to something else
other than all time yes sort of died
naturally of old age you know they won't
have to go through this devastating
process in it you know in in their final
years what are we talking about a
vaccine a cure treatment will this be
chronic treatment the way we treat let's
say diabetes yes so it's it's seeming
more and more now that it's going to be
a treatment that there has to be given
very early we know that Alzheimer's is a
disease process that evolves over
decades of time and if it actually
starts maybe 10 even 20 years before you
see any symptoms and so now scientists
are looking for these very early
telltale signs and things like spinal
fluid the blood maybe even the eye and
trying to spot the disease in middle age
and then give a patient a drug at that
point right to divert the course of the
disease entirely quickly you went to
Iceland Colombia and India to research
this what did you learn there yeah I did
travel far and wide for the book I
essentially learnt that as a scientist
you know you really should leave no
stone unturned yeah you know who would
have thought that there's a population
of people in Iceland who are genetically
immune to our Symes disease who would
have thought that there are farming
communities in India that have to have
something in their lifestyle that
protects them from Alzheimer's who would
have thought that there are groups of
patients in Colombia with early onset
Alzheimer's that are helping shed light
on the cause of Alzheimer's disease so
it's you know it's we really do need to
widen the net in search of a cure
because we're you know this is a much
more complicated disease and we'd
previously thought and so I think as a
scientist that's what I took away from
it that we really should be searching
everywhere it's a fascinating book in
pursuit of memory that fight against
Alzheimer's Georgia Belly thanks for
being with us thank you